you can go days without food
traverse unimaginable distances enjoy
relentless blizzards but if you're a
wolf on the edge of the Arctic up
against the biggest predator there's one
thing you can't do without the pack
at first glance the Arctic feels
brutally devoid of life
though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive
but the real force here works quietly
underfoot every winter sea ice starts
small and delicate then it grows over
millions of square miles how is it
possible that this freezer holds the key
to our entire planet like hello sea ice
breathes life into the Arctic every year
in a cycle that impacts the climate
across the globe this is the story from
the edge of the Canadian Arctic where it
all starts my name is Bertie Gregory and
over national geographic wildlife
filmmaker everything is at stake we're
all waiting for the big freeze
this is gray wolf territory but right
now it's also a polar bear migration
path and until the sea freezes over
these two mighty predators will have to
share this coastline
we've received the tip up about very
cool pack of wolves
reportedly they've been seen harassing
or even hunting polar bears this has
never been filmed before so we're
buzzing there now to see if we can try
and catch up with them
[Music]
wolves here are always on the move they
live in such a harsh environment that
they roam up to 1,000 square miles in
search of prey
we don't speak
that's pretty bold rule
I spent months looking for wolves before
I never seen one so once we were going
to look for them whoa let me go over the
snowdrift just on the right it's going
through the back
polar bears are the apex predators of
the Arctic weighing up to 1500 pounds no
one dares touch them except the wolves
were tracking if they can catch this bet
it would feed the pack for a week but
this bear is not having it
[Music]
there's another one there's three
there's a third one coming a big pack of
wolves could take down a polar bear but
with only three against one who is
predator and who is prey
[Music]
the bear runs the numbers and goes for
it
[Music]
[Music]
that is not a chase you see every day
you imagine chasing after a polar bear a
massive really dangerous predator when
is that ever a good thing that you
should try and eat
finding these wolves is going to be a
real challenge even though it was here
this morning this afternoon it can be 20
miles that way it would be 20 miles that
way but I guess we just got to get
really pretty lucky pretty stuff
[Music]
got ourselves a pretty good one
[Music]
[Music]
we haven't found any Wars but we have
found some of that favorite food there's
at least one moose a giant horse on
steroids it's our ninth day searching
and still no wolf pack
they just keep eluding us
[Music]
and you off the table
[Music]
we found the wolves and their sight so
trying to sneak inside it wake up this
is gonna be the most abundant stealthy
approach ever we've actually got really
lucky you were downwind of them their
sense of smell is about a hundred times
better than us so if we were upwind they
know what we had for breakfast they near
the last time we showered which wasn't
very recently they know everything about
us
[Music]
you can hear they all our different
pitches they're less like a wild a
version of an a cappella group and even
if you can you orphan then you offer the
back we'll adjust the pitch and it's how
to the rest of the back to make sure
it's no copying one of them
this big male must be alpha male he's
seems to be calling the shots and he's
got this big chunk at the side of his
face
he was running with a bit of a limp you
know one of the reasons they live in
packs is because if they get injured the
rest of the bat can still provide for
them wolf packs are also led by the
alpha female together they decide where
and when to hunt this para also the only
ones to breed adding new pups to the
pack each year they're coming over
in the movies and in the media we like
to demonize these animals but despite
being just a few feet away and never
felt any threat in those eyes just
curiosity they hung out with us like
this for over an hour until the alpha
female called the pack and off they went
[Music]
time to hunt
[Music]
there used to be two million wolves in
North America but four hundred years of
systematic extermination has left us
with just 80 thousand wild places depend
on these wolves as they regulate prey
populations
we must give them the chance to bounce
back each hunt follows a strategy first
they close in
[Music]
ready
charge
the alphys must make a quick decision
can they take down a bull moose in his
prime is this worth exhausting the
entire family
[Music]
not this time
[Music]
verified the new target
[Music]
[Music]